now when you play E4 you really want to
invest a lot of your time against black
main responses
however when somebody plays a seconded
opening like alkyne you really don't
want to waste too much time rather you
need a practical weapon where there is
no Theory required all you need is
fixed layout and attacking patents
sounds very interesting right welcome
guys as in today's lecture we are going
to witness one amazing tricky line
against the alkyne defense
[Music]
now the as usual surprise package I am
going to deliver here is Bishop to C4
this lovely crazy Gambit whereupon black
has two choices
in the first part we are going to look
what happens when black accept this
Gambit with Knight captures evil however
stay until the end as I'm going to
demonstrate what to do if black declined
this Gambit
okay Knight captures E4
and this is what I like about this game
page
what if I tell you that you are going to
sacrifice your peace adjust
third move of the game once you get
delighted
well that's the story here guys as we
have this lovely sacrifice
and with my own experience
the first reaction of black is on though
there goes my castle
so they already get a root shock
and on top of everything after this
queen check no matter however black
plays we are getting our piece back with
the interest
well more or less there are three ways
black can play from here and amongst
them if black become Really Brave and
come forward let's say King to E6 then
many instances the game can be finished
very quickly as what should insist on
grabbing the piece back with Queen to G4
whereupall black comes this far then he
has to save the peace
but now comes a lethal move
covering some important squares and the
threat is C4 which will detach the king
from the night and engine already saying
that black should play D6 and forget
about the piece but in case if you are
wondering what will happen if black
tried to save the piece here with Knight
to F6 which is in fact the course of my
game against 1800.
well I'm afraid there is a mating Five
Guys
you want to try out go ahead buddy I'm
showing you right now
Knight to C3 check King to D6 Queen to
F4 Jack
King to C6 and after Queen to C4 and
King to D6 this lovely Knight to B5
deliver the smoothest mate where in the
majority of the cases black has played
with his only King
now if you look at the database here the
majority of the games continue with G6
which you are going to face more often
and against this yep we have this simple
sequence which grabbed the piece Queen
to D5 check E6 and now you take the
Knight
so take a stop and find out what exactly
happened
well in terms of material yup both the
side is equal but in terms of King
safety yes black king has been somewhat
misplaced and it will take some time to
regroup the PCS and that is where the
fun part begins
as what white wants to do is he know
where exactly this King is
so he is going to take out his coincide
pieces Castle coincide and become
Hallows with H4 H5 which make this
variation a unique and a fun way to play
against the alkyne
let's see how we can achieve this
Bishop to G7
white plays D4 liberating the queen side
Bishop
okay black orange the artificial Castle
Rook to f8
and white should continue with Knight to
F3 so that it can support our Bishop to
G5
after King to G8
just look at these guys white every
pieces are coming out very quickly
Bishop to G5 attacking the queen queen
to E8 now you play Knight to C3
and after Knight to C6
Waters white achieve what he want to do
namely Castle on the queen side
well black is still behind in terms of
Peace development as he has not
developed his light's condition and it
doesn't matter whether they play D5 or
B6 let's say B6 here
do you remember how we can attack this
poor black king
yup this thematic break H4 and no wonder
position is looking so scary for the
black
well to illustrate the power of this
position I like to show you my model
game against a candidate Master where my
opponent continue with Bishop to B7
looking for the discovery
so I stepped out of it and now rightly
so because of the king side danger he
opened up the center with E5
well this always benefit the side who
has more developed so I accept it
and after the few exchanges Knight takes
E5 Knight takes E5 and queen takes E5
yes indeed my G2 Pawn is hanging but I
was more than happy as I can take on D7
and posted my Rook on the seventh rank
okay on the counterpart black took on G2
attacking my rook and after Rook to G1
black mates are decisive error of the
game
and to be honest it looks very natural
to play Bishop to C6 and attack this
Rook
but the only problem is what has this
lethal sacrifice Rook captures D7 which
more or less seals the victory
black queen is hanging so he has to take
back with the queen but now you see the
Tactical idea
Queen to E6
Queen to F7 and when white gobble up the
piece if you count the material
white has two minor pieces Against The
Rook which always sounds better in such
a position
in fact the game finished very quickly
my opponent took on F2 attacking my Rook
I played Rook to D1 and when black plays
rooked to E8
just one move and black resigned the
game
can you see it
congratulations if you find the deciding
blow
Knight to E4
and after this what else black is
helpless as white is attacking the queen
and when she moved we have this juicy
four coming up which unfortunately
cannot be prevented
last but not least probably the most
accurate response here is King to G8
however it doesn't change our planning
of campaign we will still give this
check and after E6 we will gobble up the
piece back
okay this time around black can play
some actives on D5
Queen to E2
and now C5 getting space at the center
of the board
well now we are going to follow a game
where Grandmaster finished his lower
rank opponent in a style
white Kickstart with Knight to F3
and if allowed then definitely D4 is on
the car so black prevent this by playing
Queen to F6
whereupon white insist on his Queen side
development starting with D3
after Knight to C6
you cannot play Bishop to G5 here so of
course Knight to C3
and after Bishop to D6 more or less same
story
Bishop G5 Queen F7 and what else yep the
castle on the coin side
you might think well the position looks
quite okay for black but see yourself as
the game finished after few moves
black plays Bishop to D7
completing his peace development but
exactly here a white strike in the
center and the move you should remember
is D4
after Pawn takes D4
Grandmaster reveal his nasty idea namely
Knight to B5 attacking the two sports
well in the game black plays Bishop to
E7
which I think is a clear bad idea
because after few exchanges Bishop takes
E7 Queen takes E7 Knight takes D4
black exchange more PCS which in turn
result
pressure on this backward pawn something
which cost him the game
okay Rook to even is coming up so black
thought that okay let me play E5 and
resolve this issue but what has been
missed out is after Knight to F3
E4
and now the killer blow Rook catches D5
where sadly enough not only black is a
clear Pawn down but look at the pathetic
position of this Rook it will take ages
to take him out
all in all if you look at the engine
Evolution over here it clearly favors
the white
okay it's time to look at the decline
variation
and let's start with the obvious move E5
can you identify what you can do
well of course no surprises D4 what else
this dangerous urso Gambit which I have
extensively covered in my dirty chance
tricks 14th and 15th episode
the second move I want to consider here
is D Phi and against this I recommend
this Simple Plan e captures D5 Knight
captures D5 and now you play this crafty
move Queen to H5 and White's main idea
is somehow he wants to make this light's
condition absolutely bad
so for example if your opponent plays E6
then he's really cooperating and white
can play a middle game where the fact
remain on the table is black always
struggle with this stupid Bishop
the same story goes if they continue
with C6
as we are going to pressurize this
Knight more with Knight to C3 and please
note this Knight cannot move as the F7
Pawn drops with a check
so by force black has to play E6
and yep we achieve our goal now we play
D4 and continue a normal middle game
where white is always slightly better
last but not least what to do against
the move E6
and here I couldn't find anything better
than E5
whereupon black has two choices
if we continue with d Phi then this
directly transpose into the hillybilly
decline variation which goes as follow
Bishop to B3
Knight to D7 and after D4
this is what I have covered in my
hillybilly decline section
where White's overall aim is he wants to
play C3 Knight to E2 Bishop to C2 castle
and then throw this F bond which give
him a good attack on the black king
well black can also play here Knight to
D5 but this is least bothersome as we
can grab the space with D4 and meeting
the Moon Knight to B6
with this lovely Bishop to D3
whereupon once again we have a simple
Target player four Knight F3 Castle
attack black on the king side where the
fact remain on the table is
black is really going to struggle to
develop his light Square Bishop
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile tricky line
against dollar kind defense
remember the choice I have given is not
even in top five lists so your opponent
has been thrown to his own resources and
it has every practical chance to outplay
your opponent and get fun and attacking
position something which we are always
looking for
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care